thank you Jim well we're getting excited
because today marks four weeks to the
day until the official launch of destiny
thank you I agree as you guys probably
know destiny has been years in the
making and it's been a real passion
project for everybody at Activision and
of course the incredibly talented team
at bungee and in four weeks time we get
to finally share bungees epic vision
with the world with destiny we think
we're unlocking the power and potential
of next-generation gaming as we said
when we first unveiled this game on the
ps4 reveal stage just 18 months ago we
think destiny brings together the
adrenaline fueled action of a finely
tuned first person action game with all
of the character investment and strategy
of a great RPG all brought together in a
vast gorgeous world that's become one of
bungees hallmarks it also delivers fun
for every type of gamer no matter how
you want to play destiny probably has a
mode that's right for you it's an
ambitious vision and PlayStation has
really stepped up and become an amazing
and important partner for us as a result
we've got a slew of timed exclusive
content experiences lined up just for
PlayStation fans ps4 players worldwide
got the first chance to play the desk of
the Alpha and then PlayStation fans also
got their hands on the destiny beta
before the rest of the world by the time
it was done across all platforms over
4.6 million people took part in that
beta play more than 88 million games in
joining more than 12 million public
events and we were thrilled to see such
a positive enthusiastic response from
gamers in fact I'm proud to be able to
announce today that according to
gamestop destiny has become officially
the most pre-ordered new IP in history
and PlayStation 4 is leading that charge
now in my job I'm lucky because I get to
work with some of the most talented
developers in the industry and I can
tell you that Bungie is a rare breed
they're one of the most creative
dedicated and talented groups of people
I've ever had the pleasure working with
so to share even more details about
Destiny's universe as well as a few
world premieres I want to bring up
someone who's been with bungie for eight
years and been one of the driving forces
behind destiny from the very beginning
bungie's director production jaunty
Barnes
hi everyone destiny has been a labor of
love for Bungie for many of us this has
been the most challenging game we've
worked on for all of our passion for
games and years of our lives into making
destiny what it is today so it was
incredibly rewarding to see millions of
people around the world playing the beta
last month to be honest we have been
absolutely blown away by the player
reaction to destiny when you put so much
into a project this ambitious is equal
parts exhilarating and humbling playing
with fans and seeing people have so much
fun makes creating games a dream job so
thank you today we want to share more
details of our fast and fun competitive
multiplayer we call it the crucible in
our beta team sort of six players fought
for supremacy in a game mode we call
control we also gave players access to
the iron banner which experience
Guardians fought for unique and powerful
rewards but that was just the beginning
for Destiny's competitive multiplayer at
launch there'll be a large variety of
maps and game modes to suit your play
style as well have tons of weapons and
pieces of armor that you can earn
customize and bring into every activity
in destiny let's take a look at the
world premiere of our multiplayer
trailer to get a peek of what you'll be
able to play on day one
thank you
destiny is a huge game it's actually way
bigger than anything we've made before
but we want to keep growing our universe
for everyone on PlayStation you'll be
getting timed exclusive access to Exodus
blue an intense multiplayer map as well
as the opportunity to face a deadly trio
of scions in the dust palace strike and
your timed exclusive access doesn't end
there we have two expansions in the
works each introducing brand-new
competitive and cooperative adventures
and new weapons and armor and player
gear today have the privilege to
announce that expansion won the dark
below will launch for everyone in
December on behalf of everyone at one
gee thank you for your support rogue see
you and your fire teams in destiny on
sep tember night thank you